hello America I'm Adam Conover and I'm
running for president of Florida
Pennsylvania and Ohio and boy do I love
Florida oranges Philadelphia
cheesesteaks and whatever you people
like in Ohio the rest of the country can
go suck a big one hi America I'm running
for president for Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan Virginia
swing states change you dumbass Adam
ruins everything electoral colleges is
something after Donald Trump swept the
electoral college not a historic victory
not a landslide but a good victory and
he's lost the popular vote by a couple
million votes a lot of people saying
this is unprecedented it's not a lot of
people saying this is unfair it's not we
need to do away with the electoral
college we don't and of course Adam
ruins everything at College Humor
emphasis on the college no emphasis on
the humor they've talked about the
electoral college and they've tried to
do this whole rebuttal on the electoral
college talking about why it's no longer
relevant so we are going to get into
this piece by piece Adam ruins
everything
namely correct information let's roll
the first clip every four years we hear
the words Electoral College over and
over again but we never talk about what
a ridiculous and frankly undemocratic
system it really is okay undemocratic
this is this is the crux of the argument
against the electoral college right it's
undemocratic yes like like they fooled
no that's by design let's start with
this okay the Marley Marley was dead to
begin with the United States has never
been a democracy and that's important
because if you understand it you look
through that prism you'll understand
where the Electoral College is necessary
these are just a bunch of quotes that
you have from some of the founding
fathers or signers talking about how
pure democracy is evil it's one of the
greatest evils Benjamin Rush wrote
because pure democracy is mob rule pure
democracy is that the mob of the
majority can infringe on the rights of
the minority now I know that left us
love to act as though they're there to
help minorities but not when it comes to
the electoral college not when it comes
to someone over and in flyover state so
that is the reason for the Electoral
College we are constitutional
representative Republic we are not a
democracy so if you understand that well
then the rest of this as irrelevant but
most people don't understand that and so
there needs to be more convincing you
let's go to the next clip the Electoral
College gives vastly more power to
different voters depending on which
state they live in bigger states nope
smaller states if your state has less
people you have more power yeah let's
keep going let's go to this clip not too
many people live in Wyoming but they
have three electoral votes or one for
every 135,000 voters California is
packed with people but they have 55
electoral votes or one for every four
hundred and eleven thousand voters okay
so they try and show percentage-wise
that there there's more representation
with Wyoming but even if you look at it
three votes to 55 with California it's
pretty minut let's bring up another clip
from everyone's favorite founding father
Hamilton let's bring up the Hamilton
quote from Federalist paper 68 the big
reason for this is because you can't
just have people pandering to a few big
cities let's stop by New York DC Los
Angeles San Francisco Detroit in the
fifties promise them a bunch of stuff
wrap this up and go home so the whole
reason to try and balance that power is
because I know these crappy states that
you think of as flyovers
we'll continue and we'll get to that
like Wyoming they can't have their vote
drowned out by people who are corralled
in the big cities I've talked about this
a lot this is why I left us want you in
big cities they want you on public
transport they want you to be dependent
on government services they want you to
think it's a sense of community robbing
from your brother through taxes and
bigger government that's why they want
you and big sis so nice it sounds so
nice but God why Wyoming shouldn't
matter as much let's get to the next
clip who cares if the Electoral College
is kooky I'm kooky I have two turtles
okay well it gets worse because the
electoral college also creates swing
states the swing states they make
election nights so exciting kinda like
when my Turtles move a little exciting I
think the fact that the entire election
is determined by just a handful of
states is really messed up for one thing
it means presidential candidates can
ignore almost the entire country do you
see the contradiction here do you just
tried to ignore the entire country that
well-versed and fly over Wyoming what
are they lawyer they represented no now
all of a sudden they care about the
little guy right because swing states
allow them to ignore the voiceless in
Wyoming who by the way shouldn't really
have that many electoral votes to
balance the powers-that-be next clip
Jerry and I'm running for president of
Florida Pennsylvania and Ohio and boy do
I love Florida oranges Philadelphia
cheesesteaks and whatever you people
like in Ohio the rest of the country can
go suck a big one hi America I'm running
for president for Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Michigan Virginia
swing states change you dumbass
swing state change that's the whole
point swing states don't say the same as
party flat platforms change at the
principle change you see that with
Donald Trump he's shaking up the whole
map let's roll this final clip because I
think it's relevant and then we'll wrap
this up thank you for the information
I cannot believe our beautiful system
has become so messed up
oh no the founding fathers designed our
system is messed up he is right the
founding fathers did design it this way
and you have a lot of stupid people they
don't understand that we're not a
democracy that we're constitutional
republic
the founding fathers they spent more ink
on this in any other branch of
government this was unbelievably
important to them the old quote on
democracy is it's basically two wolves
on deciding which land to eat for dinner
I'm butchering that but
that's the quote on democracy listen
swing states matter now they campaign
they're strategically because these are
actually generally areas of Middle
America places that would be
underrepresented if not for the
electoral college really what would you
do
New York DC Los Angeles San Francisco
Detroit back in the 50s where you
promised a bunch of Union hand out
Chicago or you cater to the Union thugs
and then all of a sudden next thing you
know people in South Dakota's are paying
for some guy in Los Angeles to take a
dump in a [ __ ] designated bathroom
that's what we don't want to happen we
don't want to burden the rest of the
country with values that not only do
they not share but are unconstitutional
right that we're so far away from
federalism and this is why we have term
limits this is why representatives are
selected or you know depending what
you're talking about legislators right
it's a representative Republic we should
have terms we should be changing these
politicians regularly but their job is
to represent people and make decisions
not simply to go alright put everything
to a popular vote that's the Bernie
Sanders well democratic socialism
doesn't change what it is democratic
slavery isn't any better democratic I
don't know cheating it POG the point is
just because people vote for something
it doesn't make it okay they don't
understand that the United States is not
a democracy
they don't understand why this matters
they don't understand why the balance of
power matters and they do understand why
we don't want to be simply like Europe
they don't understand the principles
behind federalism behind enumerated
powers why states should have their own
autonomy and why representatives should
be choose by should be chosen by a
legislature and why they should be
representing not only the people but
first and foremost the Constitution this
is one thing too from the left we've
talked about this a lot they all they're
always caring about diversity diversity
well they don't really care about this
kind of diversity right the Electoral
College is a great representative it's
emblematic of intellectual diversity
right it's emblematic of making sure
that people can have diverse states
microcosms petri dishes so you can have
crappy ones that have salmonella on
their petri dish like California or you
can have a vibrant successful one like a
strong kefir culture there in Texas
because of intellectual diversity I
don't care about the cultural diversity
in the same way that left us - I don't
care about the racial diversity at all I
certainly don't care about the gender
diversity because of the LGBTQA IP we
don't know what that means I want
intellectual diversity with
constitutional conformity borderline
constitutional fascism no wiggle room
with the Constitution intellectual
diversity constitutional conformity
that's the Electoral College